maria theresien kaserne in wien dienstag
8 uhr früh dreharbeiten der besonderen
art für einen besonderen
nationalfeiertag mit einem besonderen
regisseur oscar preisträger stefan
ruzowitzky weil sie schön fand die
themenstellung dass man ein bisschen
zeigt dass es beim hergibt dass es da
frauen gibt es gibt viele gruppen mit
migrations-hintergrund es gibt jetzt
behindertensportler die dabei sind also
dass das heer wie die gesellschaft was
auch sinn macht einfach für jeden einen
platz lebt die filme die hier entstehen
werden am kommenden nationalfeiertag im
orf zu sehen sein
es wird ein ganz besonderes event werden
am 26
oktober nicht so wie man das kennt
sondern aufgrund der korona situation
als hybride event das heißt wir werden
den heldenplatz virtuell die möglichkeit
allen österreichern geben mitzuverfolgen
die live-übertragung es wird zusätzlich
dann vom oscar gekrönten regisseur
ruzowitzky filme zu den themen unsere
leistungsschau geben und auch porträts
von soldatinnen und soldaten und der orf
der die es ja auch begleitet über drei
stunden mit einer spezial wird mit
sicherheit auch dafür sorgen dass wir
eine noch größere reichweite bei diesem
event regisseur stefan ruzowitzky legt
wert darauf die stärken des bundes
jahres besser sichtbar zu machen was wir
irgendwie versuchen
zu betonen ist halt diese dieser diese
idee der inklusion hat dass das ist ja
irgendwie etwas was das hier sehr gut
kann weiter zusammen bringen zusammen zu
schweißen und dass das ist ja glaube ich
eine ganz wichtige gesellschaftliche
funktion verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner freut sich sehr über die
zusammenarbeit mit oscar-preisträger
ruzowitzky
es ist eine wirklich ganz besonders
große freude dass uns das gelungen ist
gemeinsam mit unseren partnerinnen und
partnern ich glaube sie ist auch ein
thema das ihm selber durchaus am herzen
gelegen ist nämlich die vielfältigkeit
auch des österreichischen bundesheeres
seiner soldatinnen und soldaten ins
richtige licht zu rücken